to see something like mr. show and be
experimental know the way they would
like just bleed into sketches and stuff
like that yeah really try to open the
envelope it was like the high version
yeah but I wish we would have done that
you know yeah you know you would pitch
ideas that were a little weirder but
just because it's network and because
you know it's not you're not you're it's
not in my shell right you know you're
I'm one of many right and my curfew in
high school is midnight and that's when
it came on on HBO yeah
one night I don't know what I you know
back then you didn't know the schedule
of TV it's kind of like you came across
stuff and then when you found it you
couldn't get the information as to what
it was
unless you've got like the TV Guide or
something yeah yeah yeah so I like I
came home one night at midnight right
before I'd come home for my curfew I
would get really high with my friends
and then I go in and my stepmom would be
like watching him in the living room and
I knew I could be super high because it
was just like hey I'm back I got stairs
I'm in my own world yeah and I remember
going downstairs and like turning the TV
on it was HBO and that's what it was and
I just sat down to be like what is this
and five minutes in I was like what is
this amazing and it's so much so that I
then went to when I went to college I
went to a party one night at another
college we were playing each other in
football and I went to this party with
other guys on the soccer team and I it
was on and I the guy who lived there I
go what is this I was like what is this
Paul I was like I've seen this yeah he
was like it's mr. show D not know him is
Rizzo so I was like no tell me
everything you know about what this is
who these people are
yeah and he explained everything to me
and I told him I was like I saw this in
high school at midnight one night and
I've never I didn't know what it was and
I thought it was the most brilliant
thing I'd ever seen
yeah I got part you know the first time
you watch Holy Grail you're like what
the [ __ ] is this yeah that's I vote mr.
shows like oh my god this is unreal
don't you love back then when you're not
forced or fed or like you know how
ladies companies just [ __ ] bombard
you with advertisements yes that
discovering [ __ ] yes on your own yes
it's the wonder of back then or having a
friend show you something that you
never even heard about yes I read the
first is all Holy Grail my buddy was
like do you know what Monty Python is I
was like no he's like do you know what
Holy Grail I was like no and I spent the
night at his house one night he put it
on and we just sat there and I was like
this is this is incredible
yeah in class what am i watching when I
was in high school we should do math
anyway we got into math you're like what
is it do a little math on the side so
see a sweet town like Poway yeah with
crystal meth
well you guys have country clubs it's a
very affluent there's there was a little
underbelly and that was me I was the
underbelly of a power high yeah yeah and
so we were on meth and I think we're on
acid as well which is a terrible come
terrible combination I've never done
either you're seeing everything way too
much yeah yeah so and he was like you
got to watch Sam Raimi's Evil that you
oh my god good suggestion
yeah we turned it on and I it you know
what that scene where he had cuts his
head you ever see the movie no but this
is weird I've never done this before
there's a seance
no but two cats right now yeah Rory I am
for you okay alright Sam Raimi's Evil
Dead 2 is a masterpiece
alright of filming yeah can you edit
that to just that post amp you're like
wait what what is the show
he just convinces people watching one
movie every episode it's always Sam
Raimi's Evil Dead 2 its audio it is so
campy and fun and yeah you'd never heard
of it like you'd never a blockbuster
you couldn't really find it but I know
of it I don't know it's what that's that
exist for me and one of those movies
that there's one of those like that
genre of movies I've always known about
and I know and I haven't watched
anything Bruce Campbell ever and there's
a chance I may be loved it and I don't
know if the train has left the station
and I'll never know okay just you know
like at Blade Runner I've never watched
blade I know